please pray with me
spirit of the living god be here present
in our midst this morning today right
now this moment
for if you are here with us we know that
nothing else matters
but if you are not
then nothing else matters
in christ's name we pray amen
so when i think of easter i think of the
early morning sunlight and the empty
tomb
and the lilies and the whispers and the
spreading all and the ex hesitant but
excited joy of the disciples
i do not immediately think
of a glaring spotlight on a body that
splayed out in the middle of a dirt road
on the way to damascus with being
addressed by a voice booming from the
heavens
this is a different kind of easter
moment this morning
frederick buechner writes
of paul that his mads were madder and
his blues bluer
his pride prouder and his humbleness
humbler his strength stronger and his
weaknesses weaker than almost anybody
else's you'd be apt to think of
and the splash that he made when he fell
for christ is audible still
it's little wonder beekner says
that from the start he was a genius
at making enemies
even as a young man paul who was then
called saul in our text today he's
called saul
was already a standout leader
he was confident in his convictions
zealous and eager to prove himself he
took initiative and never shied away
from bold action
early on people began to look for to him
for approval and for direction
he's not unlike many yale students that
i know
it's as if he doused himself in charisma
daily as part of his morning ablutions
and a probably a healthy portion of it
too because rumor has it that paul
wasn't much to look at
he's described by others as being
bald-headed and bow-legged strongly
built but small in size with meeting
eyebrows and a rather large nose
and yet
his presence wafted before him and
behind him
everyone knew when he entered the room
he held the kind of power to sway a
crowd he was greatly admired i imagine
secretly envied and generally feared
our very first exposure to paul comes
in chapter 8 of the book of acts as he
is overseeing the stoning of stephen the
first of the christian disciples to die
for his confession
though you think that that may have been
enough to turn his stomach early on
he pressed on instead
ridding his world of chaos one christian
at a time
in fact he built his entire career on
keeping score he was driven by some
blend of ambition and self-righteousness
but perhaps also a little bit of
unacknowledged deep-seated sort of fear
with each arrest he was executing an
arbitrary retributive justice
that he needed to hold his identity
and his whole world together as a system
that made sense
but then it all unraveled on the road to
damascus
he heard the words come down from heaven
i am jesus whom you are persecuting
and i wonder how long the period at that
end of the sentence that breath in
between what came next
stretched out for paul as he lay there
i wonder if when he heard those words i
am jesus whom you are persecuting
if he saw immediately stephen's face
and maybe not just stephen
but all of the men and the women that he
had dragged from their homes and
synagogues across jerusalem and maybe
not just them either but all of the
people that he had exploited or abused
or even just pushed aside in his way to
the top
a huge crowd gathering around him
circling up
and i wonder if he wasn't holding his
breath
waiting
and wondering who would cast the first
stone
but instead of stones
more words came tumbling down from
heaven
it's a classic prophetic call did you
hear it get up and go
we know those words so well
and this is the easter moment because
the announcement of jesus's resurrection
for paul was also an accusation a
calling to account
but the words that follow it that
prophetic calling now get up and go
this is
a claiming a divine claiming and a
renewal of life for him
this is the easter message of both
divine justice and mercy embodied in the
one jesus christ
because in that moment paul's entire
notion of religion and justice
died
blind as he was i am sure that he could
see the ways that he had marred the
image of god and others and disfigured
it in himself as well
the systems that he had staked his life
on
suddenly seemed foolish
and small
and cruel before the cross and the
resurrection of jesus
now some christians have come to
describe their own experiences of
turning or repentance or conversion as a
sort of damascus road experience you've
heard this yes some of you might have
appropriated that language and feel
comfortable using it
so i hope that i can say without in any
way questioning the sincerity or the
legitimacy of those unique experiences
that i think that this particular easter
moment this damascus road story belongs
uniquely and solely to paul
what i mean is that we're not each of us
individual moses's called aside by a
burning bush we're not all paul's
who are
knocked down in the middle of the road
one day
i guess
his experience should neither be
like a rubric or a requirement in what
we count as christian discipleship
because just as paul himself has
emphasized in terms of the diversity of
the body the complex ways that it's so
complementary
we all encounter god's call in our lives
differently and distinctly for many of
us
much more subtly than this
we confess together regularly here in
the church because few of us have had
this kind of instantaneous turning that
paul has
we need the kind of structure and
support that we can offer each other
to name our failings and to turn again
and again repeatedly over time
in that sense i guess
meant for many of us
our liberation is often longer painfully
slower and more staggering than this
but as much as that moment was god's
unique call to paul
this easter message belongs to all of us
that christ is risen he is risen indeed
that we might be free
that we might be free from sin and
suffering and fear and death from
oppression and manipulation and
destruction and also free
from the ways that we have oppressed and
manipulated and aided in the destruction
of the image of god in others for all of
the suffering that we have called it
caused for the suffering that we have
also witnessed
either without the courage to speak or
the capacity to stop it
but once again also that we might be
free
from the million ways that we would
stone ourselves in judgment or despair
the one who created you the one who
redeemed you is the one who assures you
do not fear
i have redeemed you i have called you by
name
you are mine
christ is risen
he's risen indeed that we might be free
and christ calls us to a better way
paul walks away that day
days
days for days actually
but on the other side of it he emerges
as a fool for christ
baptized as a disciple he immediately
enters into the synagogues in damascus
the very ones that feared his coming
proclaiming jesus as the son of god
and his entire life plays out as this
sort of long ongoing confession
every time he confesses that jesus is
his savior he is confessing to right
along with it just what he has been
saved from
he boasts in his weaknesses as a living
example of god's forgiveness the power
of god's grace in jesus
and in this way paul goes right on being
his charismatic self
and making enemies left and right
only this time his charisma is founded
in a different kind of assurance and
ambition
it's no longer just this sort of
exercise of power
instead it's something closer to the
truth of the term
paul is charismatic because he has
himself become a vessel for the
outpouring of god's grace
he can't encounter another person
without seeing them as a beloved child
of god washed in grace and invited into
christ's bizarre sort of body
and knowing that god has chosen and
called and loved him even him he cannot
help but see them see them too
and he can't see them as such as
children of god beloved and grace washed
and filled and called he can't see them
that way without saying so to every
single person he encounters inviting and
exhorting them and saying look at me
look what god has done for me and know
that god can do this for you
there's no room for discretion in this
kind of mission
he's participating in god's salvation in
the world
of the world through christ one
christian at a time
may we all come to be so foolish
and so alive in christ this easter
amen